[Musique]
quelle journée glorieuse souvenez-vous de ce moment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous voulons tous les deux faire quelque chose nous allons tous les deux
faire quelque chose et nous avons
développé un lien très spécial
la vérité est que le prince héritier était
impliqué qu'il a probablement ordonné
si nous abandonnions l'Arabie saoudite, ce serait une
terrible erreur
- les jeunes pauvres exportateurs de la pyramide bili ont
abruti
ce bloc Imagi TV de la Seconde Guerre mondiale sur
un seul là-bas, dit-il, j'ai donc une grande
confiance dans mes services de renseignement, mais
je vous dirai que le président Poutine était
extrêmement  fort et puissant dans son
déni aujourd'hui quel degré de certitude
pensez-vous que Brendan Cavanaugh résultat
100%
Je n'ai jamais agressé sexuellement aucun fil utilisé
correctement pourrait être un beau spectacle
[Applaudissements] Les
républicains contrôlent la Maison Blanche mais
tout ce que j'ai à dire est tik-tok  les
conséquences de toute autre tache à la maison
sont vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est assez c'est assez le président a
demandé à l'une des autres personnes qui ont dit
maintenant pardonnez-moi madame
[Musique] le
zoom est  gratuit mais vous devez créer un
système pour le laser complice entre
la cuisine zéro supprime un
royaume optique plus passif bedico montrez-leur
[Musique]
leur ce que vous savez nous exhortons la Chine et
toutes les formes de détention arbitraire cet
accord fournit ce pour quoi nous avons été votés et
est  dans l'intérêt national avec le
parti parlementaire est-ce que
[Applaudissements]
il mérite chaque jour de la
peine de 36 mois qu'il purgera il
m'a ordonné de faire les paiements m'a ordonné
de m'impliquer dans ces affaires
afin de le protéger